على وقع انتظار صدور النتائج النهائيه في
تركيا سنستعرض معكم مشاهدينا السيناريو
الابرز في حال كسب احد الطرفين المتنافسين
الرئاسه وخسر في البرلمان الفوز بالرئاسه
بعيدا عن البرلمان سيكون غير مكتمل وناقص
وعلى سبيل المثال في حال فاز اردوغان
بالرئاسه وخسر الاغلبيه في البرلمان هذا
يعني انه سيواجه صعوبه كبيره في اداره
البلاد وفق الخبراء لماذا لانه لا يمكن
اداره البلاد بموجب مراسيم رئاسيه وهناك
حاجه طبعا للتعامل بين السلطه التنفيذيه
والسلطه التشريعيه لاقرار القوانين
والمشاريع اما اذا تعاكست نتائج
الانتخابات اي الرئاسه عن البرلمان فستدخل
هنا تركيا في ازمه سياسيه صعبه وربما
ستؤدي الى انتخابات مبكره عامه بالعموم
طبعا في المستقبل لاجل ذلك مشاهدينا تحالف
سواء كان المعارضه او الحزب الحاكم ان
يتمكن من الفوز بالانتخابات بشقيها اي
البرلمانيه والرئاسيه وفقا طبعا لخبراء
الشان التركي هنا ايضا يجب التوقف عند
نقطه مهمه جدا وهي ان من بين المرشحين
الثلاثه في السباقه الرئاسي وحده اردوغان
يؤكد ان تركيا يجب ان يحكمها نظام رئاسي
ولتغيير طريقه حكم البلاد يحتاج طبعا
الدستور الى التعديل وللقيام بذلك يجب ان
يصوت ثلثاء النواب اي 400 في البرلمان
بنعم من اصل 600 وهنا لابد من الاشاره الا
ان عدد الاحزاب المشاركه في الانتخابات
البرلمانيه يبلغ 26 حزبا وتنخرط الصغيره
منها في تحالفات مع الاحزاب الكبيره
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات